on le dit souvent la terre c'est ce que
les agriculteurs ont de plus précieux
pourtant dans le sud du Québec des
terres extrêmement riches disparaissent
à une vitesse inquiétante pour freiner
cette érosion et préserver cette
ressource inestimable des agriculteurs
travaillent de concert avec des
chercheurs
[Musique]
voici ce qu'on appelle le jardin du
Québec
des terres parmi les plus fertiles de la
province qui tapaient sa perte de vue le
paysage de la région de sherington en
Montérégie
[Musique]
ce vaste territoire de culture
maraîchère intensive est en danger
l'érosion rouge setter a un rythme
inquiétant
toi même temps réaliser que syrienne est
fait un jour il y aura plus du tout de
terre
et ce jour n'est pas si loin de temps
les terres noires de la montée régie
pourraient disparaître d'ici 35 à 50 ans
depuis les 10 dernières années on a vu
l'accélération de la dégradation de sol
parce que c'est possible
c'est quand tu prends un recul puis
l'autre organes un horizon plutôt 15 ans
20 ans
ces terres noires sont en fait d'anciens
marais lorsque la mère de Champlain
s'est retirée de la région il y a des
milliers d'années elle a laissé derrière
des lacs superficiels au fil des siècles
ils se sont graduellement refermés pour
devenir des tourbières profondes où les
végétaux accumulés et empilés ont formé
de grands dépôts de terres noires
dans les années 50 la richesse du sol a
tiré des producteurs maraîchers de la
région mais aussi d'Europe notamment des
Pays-Bas
aujourd'hui une vingtaine de producteurs
maraîchers ils font pousser des légumes
qui sont vendus partout au pays et sur
la côte Est américaine le jardin du
Québec est devenu l'un des principaux
jardins du Canada et des États-Unis
fin mai le vent souffle sur la montée
régie c'est la saison des semis et des
plantations à sharington sur les terres
de l'entreprise vedgepro un géant du
secteur maraîcher récemment vendu à des
Américains le va et vient de la machine
riz soulève des nuages semblables à de
la farine noire vous avez un couloir
devant qui remonte la rivière rudson ok
qui arrive du lac Champlain qui amène
qui a amené la création de micro climat
qui fait en sorte que on a des
conditions ici qui permettent d'avoir
des légumes très tôt en saison
le vin assèche et transporte la terre il
est en bonne partie responsable de ce
grave problème d'érosion qui préoccupe
de plus en plus les producteurs
maraîchers
[Musique]
qui perdent de la hauteur
avec son équipe Jean Caron tente de
sauver ses précieux terre 14 producteurs
maraîchers de la région participent au
projet les chercheurs ont découvert que
l'épaisseur des sols diminue en moyenne
de 2 cm par an et le vent n'est pas
l'unique cause de l'érosion
la fonte des neiges au printemps et les
fortes pluies favorisent le lessivage
des terres en vieillissant les sols
deviennent de plus en plus imperméable
la production maraîchère accélère
l'activité microbienne et l'oxydation
des Terres Noires la couche de surface
se décompose et le sol s'affaire
enfin la circulation de la machinerie
lourde compacte le sol
conséquence l'épaisseur du sol diminue
depuis 60 ans on le voit bien le long du
rang Saint-André la baisse du niveau du
sol est saisissante
beaucoup plus élevées pratiquement au
même niveau de la route
Raphaël de Ragon essaie d'identifier les
secteurs les plus touchés par la
dégradation il prélève des échantillons
pour mesurer la profondeur des sols et
cartographier l'état des champs
70 cm de profondeur on tombe dans cette
fameuse transition là vers le sol mirage
donc si on a affaire un champ qui est de
profondeur
relativement faible puis ça c'est un
seul site dans tout le champ qu'on voit
ici
plus le sol est mince plus il devient
difficile à cultiver et puis on retrouve
sous cette mince couche de terre noire
une couche grise gélatineuse et
imperméable ce sont pas des couches qui
sont désirées pour l'agriculture
pourquoi parce que ça va garder des
nappes très élevées dans le champ donc
le champ va moins bien se drainer va
avoir moins bonne aération pour les
racines des plans
aujourd'hui Raphaël de Ragon et le
professeur Nicolas Lefebvre arpente se
vaste champ
des disques derrière leur véhicule trace
des sillons dans le sol et en mesure la
salinité
la machinerie permet aussi de prélever
automatiquement des échantillons sur une
grande superficie pour mesurer la
résistance et la compassion du sol
ils obtiennent le portrait de la
profondeur du sol sur l'ensemble du
champ et peuvent ensuite déterminer les
ondes d'intervention prioritaires
des stations météorologiques ont aussi
été installées à des endroits
stratégiques
elles servent à cartographier la
direction des vents et a déterminer à
quelle vitesse il souffle au niveau du
sol
cela permet de mieux positionner les
ébrises vent et de les rendre plus
efficaces par exemple on a rajouté de
nouvelles espèces à cette vieille haie
de peuplier pour qu'elle soit plus
étanche il y avait des espèces au pied
qui sont graduellement disparus avec les
années faites qui sont maintenant
restaurées ça permet à ce moment-là de
protéger ces parcelles là contre le vent
de l'ouest qui dans cette région-ci est
très heureuse tout comme l'avant du Sud
qui lui aussi hétérosif durant les
périodes de tempête
mais pour mesurer avec précision
l'ampleur de la perte de sol associée à
l'érosion éolienne les chercheurs font
des essais en soufflerie
un moteur absurde un déplacement d'air à
l'intérieur du canal de la soufflerie on
soumet des échantillons de sol à
différentes vitesses de vent ça nous
permet aussi de faire varier plusieurs
paramètres du sol comme sa rugosité de
surface son humidité de surface
l'origine du sol lui-même parce qu'en
action plus fin donc son plus grossiers
c'est le prototype que qu'on a imprimé
plus loin un chercheur crée un vortex
dans un petit cylindre pour quantifier
les pertes de sol lors du passage d'un
tourbillon de sorcière
il s'agit d'un tourbillon qui se forme
lorsque de l'air sec et instable en
rotation soulève la poussière du sol
c'est un phénomène météorologique
difficile à observer sur le terrain
ces tests permettent de mesurer
l'humidité idéale du sol et donc
d'adapter l'irrigation des champs
lorsqu'elle est sèche la matière
organique est très légère mais si elle
est humide l'eau crée une cohésion entre
les particules ce qui rend le sol
beaucoup plus lourd et réduit l'érosion
on va recommander une application d'une
dose minimale d'eau pour rétablir le
contact entre les particules fines de
surface pour leur redonner du poil
au fur et à mesure que les chercheurs
documentent les pertes de sol les
producteurs maraîchers eux passent à
l'action et adoptent de nouvelles
pratiques de conservation pour réduire
l’érosion à l'hiver et au printemps ils
utilisent les engrais verts ces plantes
qui recouvrent encore le sol au moment
des semis sont maintenant utilisés sur
plus de 80% des terres cultivées la
technique est reconnue mais mal adapté à
la culture maraîchère
c'est c'est difficile on n'a pas encore
les équipements comme dans le maïs par
exemple ou ce qu'on voit soumise dans
beaucoup de débris on nous nos types de
savoir qui existent c'est des savoirs
qui travaillent avec des plus petites
savantes puis moindrement qu'il y a des
débris sur le chemin ça cause ça cause
des dommages c'est pas capable en ce
moment assez adéquate même
Jean-Marie zoumstein et sa sœur
madeleine produisent de la coriandre et
des oignons verts dans la région de
scherwington ils assistaient impuissants
à l'accélération de la dégradation des
sols ils n'ont pas hésité à collaborer
aux travaux de recherche
c'est notre usine c'est vraiment notre
camping puis on veut vraiment tout
mettre en oeuvre pour le conserver le
plus longtemps possible et le garder
ensemble
fait partie de l'équipe de Jean Caron
est-ce que tu as une idée de la mise en
culture de ce site là ici
70 ça peut très l'eau
faut surtout agir avant qu'il soit trop
tard
depuis 5 ans Jean-Marie Zumstein a
ajouté des copeaux d'érables dans une
parcelle de terre dans une autre de la
fibre de miscanthus l'objectif c'est de
trouver un matériau que les
micro-organismes de la difficulté à
décomposer pour limiter la dégradation
du sol
la dégradation c'est vrai ça va faire en
sorte que cette perte de hauteur là ça
devient une restriction pour la
croissance des cultures donc le loup va
avoir de la difficulté à s'écouler elle
va rester dans le profil de sol et ça va
entraîner des problèmes au niveau des
maladies rascinaires au niveau du manque
d'oxygène pour les racines et donc des
conséquences sur les rendements les
essais montrent qu'au fil des années le
miscanthus en se décomposant lentement
relâchent des nutriments et de l'azote
dans le sol et améliore sa productivité
en gros vraiment une amélioration de la
structure parce que le sol il devient
très dense il est comme devenu très
dense très peu perméable à l'eau
chez les hommes Stein le constat saute
aux yeux les propriétés et la structure
du sol s'améliore tu as eu un impact
aussi sur le rendement mais on a
vraiment vu que la qualité du produit
est émaillère dans la section miscanthus
puis aussi dans la section résidu
forestier mais un petit peu moins
frappant que dans le miscanthus
les haies de miscanthus spectaculaires
ont donc un triple rôle elle freine
l'érosion du vin restructures et
restaure les sols quand elles sont
plantées sur des sites dégradés puis une
fois fauchées et broyée en copeaux le
miscanthus retourne de la matière
organique dans les sols en culture
mais quels sont les amendements les plus
efficaces
des échantillons de sols prélevés à
sherington ont été déposés dans ces
cylindres dans une serre de l'Université
Laval
le fait d'être enceinte nous permet de
simuler les conditions qu'on rencontre
aurait en trois ans de chant en l'espace
d'une année c'est que ça permet donc de
voir sur une période de 5 ans qu'est-ce
qu'on devra attendre sur une période de
15 ans à condition d'opération de
terrain
conclusion le miscanthus et le saule
sont les plus efficaces pour maintenir
la hauteur du sol on peut assurer la
durabilité donc le maintien des
propriétés hydrauliques les propriétés
d'aération les propriétés de stockage
d'eau de ces soldats puis donc leur
capacité de produire
un laboratoire comme sur le terrain
l'opération sauvetage des terres noires
de la montée régie représentent un
chantier gigantesque
la mission est d'autant plus importante
que ces terres ont encore aujourd'hui
une très forte valeur foncière et
l'équipe de recherche est optimiste
et on pense que en ayant à peu près le
tiers des terres d'après ce qu'on peut
voir qui sont en restructuration
restauration on va pouvoir sauver les
deux tiers qui vont rester puis
éventuellement se tient là va pouvoir
retourner à la production quand les
autres deviendront des zones de
production biomasse
le défi pour les producteurs maraîchers
de la région sera de mettre en place des
mesures de conservation sans trop faire
grimper les coûts de production car ils
doivent demeurer concurrentielles dans
un marché très compétitif
dans cette ressource
tu veux pas perdre cette potentiel qui
existe